>>> WE ARE BACK.
U'G CNN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FINAL DAYS I
S REINDAYS IN OFFICE.
O T ME
RE
HANNG TO STCLEAR OF THE
ORBITCNN PEDENT BRASHR IS BREA
BARBARA,O THOS O THE PN ONE OFN
OFFICIALS DON'T EVNO IS PRESIDET
SAYING?
E GENERAL
M SO MANY ACMO ITA  TRS  PRESID
TA SY DOESN'T FOLLOW
EM.'T FOLLOW ILLEGAOERD
N AND OF ITSELF IS IN RECENT  BE
AVPLE INVA ARE VN HIS AIN OF THO
OVERTURN THE ELE
RETIREEUTENAE
FLYNN.
UR
HE OPENLTAG AB
ABOUT RYCAPABILIESECTIONS OR CEN
OUTCOMES IN SWSTATESE MILITAS A.
S. ONY
THOMAS, FORMER HEAD OFPE
OPERATIONS IN AND OF HIM IS
VERYENTIALMMUNITY HAEE
CAUGHTUR ATTENTI
GENERAL THOMD, I WANT TO T  ERY
YOKNVERAGING THERY TO RERUN ELE
THE .
YOU'RE ALSO UNDEHEY TRD
." A MA EDO ANOTHER RETIRED  WHS
CAPABILIN RERUNNINILITARY
ELECTIONS INTA  WHEE ARE.0 DAYS
SWORN IN.
, "STOP.JUSTSAYS.
BARBARA STAR, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
REPORTING.
WITH DEMOCRATIC SSWOMALOTKIN O
MICHFORMER CIA AA ENSE DFICIAL M
NTLY O
E ND
SE CTT
NGT VE
ONE.
YOU JUST HRA'S REPORTABTOLITARY
BRASS, A NEXT
UPP
THEY DON'T KNOW,, DO MG LISTS T
O. WOULD BE YO TOP CONCERLY I T
PENTAGON FOLLO SORT OF A
TY LEADERSP.THEY'ROK THES EE AT
REACT.
I'VE BEE
E SECRETARARMYY PUT.ERE'S OLE MY
IN THERANSITION, I
GENERAL MILLIEAIRMAN OE T CHIEF
NT
LEAVE IT HANGIG
HETIONS.I UNDERSTA ANXIETY ADER-
NEEDS TO BE
FR TOP.
>> YOUBA, LOS EF S A LECOMMAND,S
SOLARWDSACY BELIEVES
COULD TURN OUT TO BEHE LST
ATTACK ON TH EVER.LEASEMS LTRAT.
ENERGYEPARTMENT
RUSSIA BEINGLAD.IDT IGRES RT NO
THE PRESIDENEC B
INHERITING ALL OF .
JUST T AS ONCESTT  YOU OVERSA
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TOEE THE
PRESIDENECBOUT R
E DECISI ACTION, A H
IT'S NOT TANK K OR RPNE'ST OFN
D  SDOLEA ER C
ATTACK AND NO .EL LIKECA
HAV
THAT MEANS THEID
ADMINISTRATION HAS TY
R FR
AS THE RUSSIANS.
ERE HAS TOCONSEQUENCES
I O WORK FHITO FIG ARE OW WHAT
ARELKING SANCTIONS, BOO
WHETHER WE'RE BETYE ID WE CAN J.
AS AEXQUISITE .T DO ANYTHING AB
IT, IT'S N PALATABLE OSSIBLE F
YEARS.
>> I WAS TALKINGFORMER DNI PER .
HED TO MROR F ALL OF THIS, IT
TENTIALLY A GOLDINE.STL TON FROF
DO YOUTI
TALKING ABOUT?
>> WELL, I'VE BEEIVING
BRIEFINGS TOUGH M
ROE NDCOMMITTEE AND THMED RVITT.
UNDERSTAND THF ACT
I THINK EVERY SINGLEYORY DAYW OA
ED.
NGO RE OUT WHAT THE DAMAGE WAS.
ORDEVASTATING.
RI
PRIVATE CONVERSATIONS THAT W
HA B AMBASRS
BERYFFICIALS.
REITIONS
ARE.
NINGE KINDS OF THING
THAT'SYOU KNOW, JUST SENSITIVEI.
ADVERSARIES
WI
.
IT'S JUST PUTSIS
DISADVANTAGE NOT GOOD R
ANYTHING, CONGREMA ES OE AISLE.
OV RELIEF,
$6 CS FOES.
PROBLEM-G UCTEREST IBIPARTISANS
SOME OF YOUR COLLEAGY THE  ENOU
MORE?
K SIX MONTHSD GOTIATIONS LITERA
ISA SHORT-TERM DEAL THAT
WEEN
HA PREDE WHE
ALSO HLY A TH.
RIGHHOPEFULLTHT WILL B OF TH W.T
EVERYONEANAT'S THE NATURE OF C T
END BE GOT, WE WOULDN'T HAVE A
ALD
DN'TAVE ANYTHING.DDITION TO BE
PERSON, IT'S0 PECH THEN CONTINON
UNEMME
PEN OU
PLOYMENT AND AEXA $300PER CHECK.
PLENTY OF THINGS DIDGET IN I
THOUGHOUE BEEN IN,
IDED GOVERNMENGO, E.
IT'S NOT A THE MISS. E THATG APA